i'm gonna level with you i'm overwhelmed
there's so much damn crap going on in my
life i can't keep up it gives me stress
so
thanks to better help for helping me
with therapy to work it on out and
thanks to better help for bringing you
this dope ass clip
you know what i've been really
fascinated by lately i've been seeing
videos about lil xan who was [ __ ]
huge big deal making a ton of money i
heard a lot of videos that's so funny
that you brought them up today because
i'm looking at i'm looking at thumbnails
and they're and they're [ __ ] up with
they're saying that he fell not fell off
but like
bro he's broke and he's in a hospital
he's in a hospital bed to uh i saw him
today in the hospital bed with ivs in
him or something like that i mean yeah i
don't know about that it's like night
before last i i saw a couple videos i
thought
let me tell you something
i i i've communicated with him uh
multiple times um the the
the kid was clean for a while
yeah and um
and i called him the last time i talked
to him i said um lausanne you're acting
different
and i'm like and
and he's like why are you he's like why
do you think i'm acting different like
brother i don't know what's going on
you're definitely out from zans again
he's in the hospital and he's not he's
often stands again but but uh he's he's
i'm not gonna speak about his business
but he's off that cocaine i mean cocaine
and all i mean yeah but yeah i mean the
story that i get from just like what
what i see
is that his problem was
that he didn't have the work ethic he
did not have the work ethic and to be
honest as i called him
he's um
he's kind of a softy man
he he had like it sounded like he gets
walked all over yeah he takes eve people
take advantage of them and and uh he
this whole blaming everybody else yeah
blaming everybody and he stays and he
stages the tana mojo dating him and
stuff like that he admitted to me i'm
like bro i i mean i'm not really
interested where's your head it's like
bro are you a lost cause are you a
rapper which one are you well yeah what
was particularly fascinating to me is
all these people
like i think uh
maybe one was he talks about his manager
there's these people who are in his
circle but they're saying that with his
g wagon he can't afford the thirty
thousand dollars to pay it off that he
doesn't the guy's saying i'll bet my you
can cut off my arm if he has thirty
thousand dollars like he does he's broke
and
and i look at his instagram and it's him
like coming off a [ __ ] private jet in
a fleet of rolls royces and i just think
to myself it's so tragic when people
feel that they have to maintain an image
of like a flashy card
listen admitted to me that he's not he's
not he's not an image he doesn't he
doesn't he's not in in for it for the
image yeah he's got face tattoos but he
admitted to me that he he admitted to me
i talked i had a long conversation with
him four hours five hours in the middle
of night but i think he is for the
because he knows i have to be in a
mansion or something like that maybe but
he admits me he's like i'm a regular guy
i'm this and i'm someone i'm like that's
perfectly fine i still like that but um
yeah i mean it's uh the work ethic is
the problem the work i think is is what
everybody can agree on and and where you
guys i mean where's the music
you guys
seem to evidently have a work ethic and
that's like the the most important piece
and dude like what you guys gotta be in
you
yeah what you just did for us with that
freestyle i mean
that's what people need to know about i
could do that all day all day long
freestyling
i mean that sound you know i used to
watch um cyphers with uh little pump and
stuff like that and he's making me laugh
it was hysterical i mean dude it's epic
as hell dude now
like when you you brought up six nine
earlier and and uh said that you were
insulted to be uh to be comparing that
was before i was even famous i was
insulted when i was in county and there
and and the guy kept calling me trippy
red i'm like i'm going to punch this old
40-year-old ball guy
but he kept calling me trippy real
what's up trippy red i brushed my teeth
trimmed me right yeah they'll call it
they'll call you here no they'll call
you different rappers you know what
trivia is right i do yeah what i don't
look like trippy red why'd you call me
trippy red cause you got tattoos on your
face you know how i got into therapy i
went to betterhelp.com
yeah man it was very simple they asked
me what my issues were what i wanted to
work on i plugged it in and they matched
me with the perfect therapist yeah like
they've got a whole network of super
qualified professional therapists and if
you go to betterhelp.com
that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com slash
stevo then you get 10 off your first
month and i believe in it man i do it it
very much helped me and i think there's
a good chance that it could help you too
so go to betterhelp.como
give it a shot and you get 10 off your
first month and i think there's a strong
chance that you might be a happier
healthier person for doing it so thank
you to better help for sponsoring this
podcast and hooking up the listeners of
the wild ride yeah baby now let's talk
about that stressful situation